taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
it's another episode of taste buds we're
the taste buds i'm joe that's sal
yes how are you taste buddies doing good
to see you at that
gang yeah good to see you and this is
pre-recorded
so i don't know how it's going but i'm
just going to say thank you for all the
support we're overwhelmed
yeah we're we're kind of stockpiling a
few so we can come at you
with a bank of episodes but we are
having a blast doing this
and by the way if you're new to the show
and you haven't heard this before
uh this is a show where sal and i debate
foods
uh we're very passionate about food uh
in our private life we talk a lot about
food in our private life
and uh we argue a lot about food in our
private lives so we
are taking those arguments and
disagreements because we find them fun
and passionate and bringing them to you
the public and we also are going to do
this poll
every week uh where we take the actual
debate
about the foods we're having to twitter
so at the end
we can see who the public agrees we put
the poll up at the very top of the
episode as in right now
and then and at the end of the half hour
we go to the polls and we use that as
the answer
for our record-keeping purposes yes yes
so
nobody really i wonder i wonder who and
and maybe come one day we might even we
talked about all the variants
all the ver like the variables that we
could do here whereas if you and i feel
super passionate about something
we can bring on a friend or another
comic and it's me and you tag teaming
against two of our comic friends or
something like that or
you know like we might even venture out
and to have let's say like
someone that you know that makes an
amazing dish versus that same
dish versus someone i know there's so
many ways we might go with this right
yeah
might have we might have always have all
on guests that i can have on my team and
your team
right and it makes a real nice round
robin situation right right and then
obviously
you know it would be great to get this
out in front of a live
audience oh that's great really and
we've had ideas for that too we have
big ideas for that fun participatory
ideas
i have ocd so i need my mic see your mic
i need you to i need you to pull that
down you know what had i seen it on
yours i would have said you got to pull
it down
your friend this is no this is actually
i need it to be better and
and i i've been i've been seeing it for
a while now and i
i i yeah that's nice i can't believe you
didn't tell me so now it's nice
i could use a little more a little more
toward you
yeah now push it down and push that down
i know what you want i know what you
like hold on
yeah that's so nice now yeah it's
perfect yeah thank you
i really i really got to be honest like
i was staring at it and i don't know why
i didn't say that i got news for you
yours is a little
crazy you need
you want me to do it for you yep see did
you see it you saw it didn't you
i told you this is why we have a show
see now you pushed it too much and now
it's off again yeah i don't agree
now i don't agree you can take a look at
that yourself
i swear to god nope it's a little just a
teeny bit off but it's okay
we're going to let it go we're going to
let it go yeah
that the other direction other direction
other direction see it's crooked you can
see
this is good enough for me all right
turn turn it to me
label side show me label side
obsess i've bad ocd i know people say
that but i really do i have two things
bad i have three things bad adhd
ocd and sleep apnea i have it out the s
no no label side
yeah that'll do yeah
no worries yeah we decided to loosen up
with this one today
yeah today partake the uh cheers folks
uh today's uh where are we at time-wise
mike
that's it it felt like a long time just
you're kidding me he said go we talked
about this and that's it
did you hit your head we would do it i
thought it was going to say one minute
when he said five i'm like time's flying
and you said that's it shows where we
feel what we feel about this situation
right now
i'm having a grand old time you know
what they say bad time yeah but you
you think time's crawling right now i
thought we talked about that mic cover
for 10 minutes straight
but that could be the upside most likely
our listeners felt that way yeah
i felt like that was forever um our
subject today our debate today
uh it's very near and dear to my heart
uh this is a
bit of a twist the first three episodes
we did which is the better
of the two things yeah oreos versus
chips ahoy
apple pie versus peach pie uh and
cinnamon raisin versus everything bagel
today we're debating what is the worst
of two things and we each pick the thing
we hate
and they're both from the fruit family
yeah and i
say near and dear to my heart because
the fruit i'm going after
yeah that you like yeah i i
i have hated this fruit my entire
life okay just to tell you we flipped
the script a little right so like
the rules aren't always the same so i'm
not the fruit i'm gonna be defending
i enjoy i don't think it's the best it's
not my favorite fruit but you hate it
i hate it and i enjoy it so that's
enough for me
for him to argue that it's bad and so
the fruit that you like
i do not like so what we decided we
flipped the script a little bit
and so we're debating in the same spirit
but we're not debating that one is
better than the other what you just said
i'm not even debating that
the thing you're gonna defend is your
favorite
no it's not even that it's you have a
hatred for one that i don't
and i have a hatred for one that you
don't but we like those respectively
right so we are still saying one's
better than the other in the sense of
the one the one i the one i have to
defend in some way i think is better
than the one i'm [ __ ] on yeah but
the difference is
is that the other debates we had we were
talking about what we thought was the
top tier of that
item with this one we're taking two
mid-range things
but we're going to argue that one is
worse than the other
yes or that and that one is the worst of
all the fruits
yeah of the worst of these two fruits i
my pick is the worst of all fruits
but i thought we changed it from worse
fruit worst
fruit to worse fruit well it is worse
between these two for the sake of this
argument
hot in here um i don't know
the uh adhd uh in the twitter poll we
phrased it which is the worst
of these two fruits yeah because if we
wrote what is the worst fruit
yeah people would have said well i don't
think either of these is the worst yeah
yeah uh but but for all intents and
purposes
i am saying i'll spill the beans that
the cantaloupe
is the worst fruit that's ever come down
maybe if i was five years old and have a
palette i agree with you because i i i
barked at a pan
uh cantaloupe my whole life but now uh
now you're old and you're beautiful
beautiful ripe
summery cantaloupe some cottage cheese
in it i uh no
disgusting i don't know what kind of no
i don't like how to cheese on my fruit i
don't like how to choose my fruit
uh but i will tell you this even the
smell
of a fresh cantaloupe really gets me
going you mean though do you mean the
the no smell that it has no i mean the
smell the match at zero fl
look i don't want to say too much before
we look at this they're using
cantaloupes as a bowl
yeah that's cottage cheese in the middle
that's what that one over there is
granola it is what it is all i'm saying
is cottage cheese with granola
in it okay disgusting but what i'm
saying is pretty freaking cool that you
could use it as a bowl
i could use a human skull as a bowl
does that mean listen start a nice skull
with a little cream cheese
got his cheese steak what is cottage
cheese it's curdled cheese
disgusting i could i could i have to be
in the mood
can i tell you something real quick
before you go into your fruit
because we have to hit the pole start
too
uh our dear friend i'm gonna out him on
this right now big j
okarson oh sure one of our best friends
in the world right
uh he he asked me to come over for
dinner one night early quarantine
okay okay early quarantine he goes you
want to come over for dinner i'm going
to cook
i go yeah dude he goes come over
thursday it's tuesday
uh i go yeah thursday night that works
great he goes great dude i'm making
you ready for this dish sweet and sour
meatballs
with cottage cheese on the side i was
no i love jay and that's i love him but
you even surprised me with that i don't
even understand that must be a thing it
must be
a um a geographical
jersey a geographical yeah uh i go i go
sure dude no problem because i didn't
have the heart to say no
i sound good
[Music]
and you know what's so funny if you know
if you really know you that's
completely true yeah you had anxiety
over the meal your friend was making
three days later i didn't i was like i
don't want to eat that i don't know how
to get out of this
i feel like it as well and then
something came up and he cancelled
and i was like did you ever tell him
this no well
hopefully jay listens to tastebuds i
didn't have the guts to tell
not the guts the heart i felt because i
feel like
proud of this dish now i will say this
uh not an episode goes by we don't
mention one of our vacations
we were on vacation recently i start to
talk about the gravy the tomato gravy
and sausage or meatballs and i make that
wasn't the vacation
that was the most recent one i was
talking about one night because you made
it on
the first one i made it yeah yeah this
one this summer yeah talking about
making it yeah
there was some debate about whether it
was going to be too heavy a dish for the
hot weather whatever
and i said well i don't want to make it
if we're not going to eat it if nobody's
excited i'm not going to make it
too much work and then jay very
flippantly said
i could throw a sauce together based on
that remark
i'm sitting now on the sweet and sour
meatballs
because he was a real strike against wow
i mean that was a real
jab jay's gonna have to come on in the
future yeah and maybe team with me
against you for something because i i
honestly believe too
we will also have a segment at the top
where he defends the swedish
uh the sweet and sound meatballs with
cottage cheese i'd like to hear that
i'd like to hear that that's basically
that's also how we should book our
guests too
like something happened that was like
ill-conceived or something
one of us thinks it's the best meal
they've ever had or an ill-conceived
meal so there's an organic reason to
bring jay on
and he can come on and defend defend his
dish that could be a segment
yeah maybe a little treat a little
defend your dish because you got some
let me tell you something else you got
some sandwiches that also like you have
some
some recipes that sound on paper
like right not good
not good right and you ate him you
made me a sandwich and we won't get into
it now right we could always bring it
back
it's what would you call the kodo salami
the the type of salami on it was kota
salami yeah and you
described this sandwich and it didn't
sound that good because it was like we
thought we're gonna use
we'll get into this but and i to your
credit
ate the sandwich delicious yeah so
maybe you're not giving jay okerson
the you're not you didn't give the dish
a chance
do you want any cottage cheese i will
say that i'm not
crazy crazy adventurous like when it
comes to like i don't like
certain foul like that's another episode
we have to have because
you cook goose but like um yeah i will
say like but
things i've had and then we'll that for
to be mixed
together i will i will try that so while
i will tell you
jay's dish does not sound appeasing to
me on paper i would be game
to try it for sure cottage cheese looks
like cheese well that's going to bring
it on
that you'll taste it live i'm not
putting it in my lesson to cook that
down i won't put it in my mouth but
don't be silly here we're here we're
here for work
cottage cheese looks like cheese you mix
water in with
cottage cheese just i think cottage
cheese is a fresh cheese
no thank you by the way did you make the
font bigger thank you mike because i
cannot see
this okay cottage cheese is a fresh
cheese known for its small
curds i mean already it sounds
disgusting slightly savory and creamy
taste
is made by acidifying milk which results
in the curd
separating from the whey it's literally
from a nursery room
after the curds are formed they're
rinsed rinsed yeah and some
salt may be added so it's curdled
milk that has the water in it like i
just said right
i didn't even know they really will say
like i i've had a spoonful of cottage
cheese and not
felt it was lumpy but it wasn't like let
me gag this out of my mouth it looks
like if you
eat would like eat brains what's curds
and white yeah that's true what's
cursing away from again
along came a spike little miss muffet
sat on a tuffet
eating your curds and whey but she was
eating cottage cheese yeah this is a
snack a child ate in 1796
when that poem was written it's
disgusting
[Laughter]
jay wants to put on top of meatballs
so i just blew my balls oh no we got to
send this out
what is the worst shape but you got to
say what your fruit you're going at au
pair baby pear
come on no one all right i won't even
say it but the worst well the worst
fruit of these two
is a pear a pair is worse than a
cantaloupe and it's a tweet
courage in way i never realized my
entire life that little miss
little miss muffet by the way what is
that her last name
i guess so what does that even mean the
lewis muffet she's like a little girl oh
by the way
what is a tuffet sat on a tuffet it's a
chair
a tufted chair maybe a tuft yeah i think
it's yeah
in the rhyme miss muffet sits on a
tuffet eating a curds and white today's
cottage cheese is similar to curries and
white
i can't believe that she was eating
cottage cheese
uh and way that would have been popular
400
years ago 100 years ago how did you even
come close like
that is like it was 1600 it's not even
1796 but
i don't know i assume this is an old
cottage
400 in the 1600s so can you can you
google the rhyme
because i want to know who miss muffet
is and what a tough it is
maybe go wikipedia like etymology look
up the definition of tough it
there you go tough it a lot the word
tough it is now sometimes used
to mean a type of low seat yeah it's
like a little you know oh like a like a
little like a little like a little um
like almost like an ottoman but like
what are they called like they call them
they call it all right they call them
poofs now yeah footstool yeah footstool
so and is she and is miss muffet her
last name
yeah her name is little miss mustard
this is a rhyme about a woman
sitting on a small stool eating cottage
cheese oh my god look at this the
origins of the rhyme
1805. you could see that it says was
found before
you 1805 i guessed it almost within nine
years
you guessed it within a decade are you
kidding me holy [ __ ]
you couldn't do that again i mean you
that is wild that is why
1805. you said 1796. i'm shocked by that
so there she's in a field she's
sitting on a stool she kicked it over
and she's eating a bowl of cottage
cheese it's disgusting along came a
spider sat down beside her and said
what's in the bowl [ __ ]
what is the rhyme how does it go can you
i can't read that buddy
uh i mean i can't where we at time was
hold on a second
sixteen all right we gotta start the day
all right all right but no but sometimes
we have a little side trip yeah yeah we
sighed
we decided pretty good into miss muffet
okay
so along eating our curds and whey there
came a little spider who sat down beside
right now and frightened miss muffet
away
that's it that's the whole thing wow did
you remember it being heavier i wonder
it was based on a true story i thought
it was
more than that like it kept going no
it's a nursery rhyme
it's like a little you know i don't
think a little kid reads
don't nurture rhyme flex on me because
you get you guessed it within i was i
mean you guessed
but i'm saying like it's yeah you're not
like like you're not an authority on
a nursery but you know nursery rhymes
are really short that's the whole thing
is they're they're short i know i know
yeah yeah you know like by the way
a girl was sitting on a stool eating
cottage cheese a spider made a jump up
and take a take off she ran away
and they only named her muffet so they
could use the word tough fit i mean
that's
really it's lazy writing when you think
about it it's about a girl named
wait a minute what does the nurse around
little miss muffet mean
little miss muffet is about a girl named
patience
who was dr muffet's step-daughter
the lyrics probably tell the story of an
incident when patients
ran away from her breakfast being
frightened by a spider
from dr muffet's collection dr muffet
had spiders that opens up a world of
questions and a whole new world in my
mind
yeah that's that's uh patience muffet
wow it's a real chick that's weird and
that her father was a spider doctor
well i don't know if i took that away
from it instead of she was thinking he
was a doctor with a spider collection
there's no spider doctor i mean why
would he have a doctor no one's like
rushing in like breaking like knocking a
door and be like doctor
our spider is on the way out no but i
mean no i don't mean like he fixed
spider i mean he was like a doctor like
a scientist like an insect scientist or
something i don't know what that's
called but
i see him it's just as he had a
collection
i think he had he was a doctor who had
an affinity for us he had a spider
collection all right
and then his daughter was named patience
by the way patience muffet
jumped up ran out of there immediately
when she saw the spider she had no
patience with it whatsoever
maybe the irony we gotta do the debate
okay it's not nursery but
okay okay okay all right all right yeah
yeah
what a deviation a deviation i like the
other day when you left me a message and
he said we're going on a little
adventure
and like because i talk i i feel like we
you know we start to take each other's
lingo
right but patty walsh and i on we'll see
patty walsh and i always abbreviate
here's a weird thing this is again why
you and i are such good friends patty
walsh and i also abbreviate all the time
and we have for years which is why when
you did it i was like oh
here brief he does the abbreviations
yeah you know and i do it with justin
silver too
patty walsh and i also say babe all the
time yeah isn't that crazy i feel like
everyone talks away but maybe they don't
no they don't you're the only other one
i know that does that like and then
like it's just have fun with your words
that's a fan of yours it's just so weird
because it's like it's like here's two
guys or two dear friends of mine
and i've never met pat yeah who i know
completely separately and i
they both do this thing that makes me
laugh and i do it with them
yeah that's great weird it is it is
anyway let me see my whisk
all right my whisk
[Laughter]
uh but here's the thing okay cantaloupe
you could tee off because you're going
to lose this so you get tea off
i know i actually know i'm going to lose
it which bothers me because cantaloupe
in the spirit of competition
cantaloupe is a worthless fruit and let
me tell you what i mean by that you
think lope
lope is a worthless fruit lopez and
worthless
fruit okay it's it's it is the packing
peanut
of fruit it has ruined i can't tell you
how many fruit salads
at a barbecue for me somebody makes a
beautiful fruit salad with
with grapes and cherries and pineapple
and all this wonderful stuff in it
and then all that stuff is so sparingly
spread throughout the fruit salad
the entire fruit salad is cantaloupe or
god forbid honeydew i mean the two of
these
honeydew i hate all so you hate all
melons you hate watermelon
watermelon if i wanted a tasteless mealy
fruit
i need a rotten apple wow watermelon
sucks you hate all melon i hate it i
gotta tell you when a melon is ripe
so you the ubiquity of a cantaloupe
doesn't
clue you into the fact that it's worthy
of its status
you know what's never ever and i mean
ever
and i'm talking about from about mitzvah
to a wedding from a craft service table
to someone's fridge you know what's
never on that tray
you know what it is you're gonna say
pear no of course i am
yeah yeah well i'll tell you this right
now do you like fruit cocktail
cause pear is the cornerstone of fruit
yeah but i like fruit cocktail but it
takes the rest of the cocktail
to bring the pear up to par the pear is
punching above its weight in a fruit
cocktail
and i tell you what it's my least
favorite bite of the cocktail if you
gave me a fruit salad with cantaloupe in
it i would eat everything around the
cantaloupe and throw the cantaloupe you
and you alone
even eat people might not like
cantaloupe i didn't like it until i
i was a little older but nobody i've and
i'll tell you something else
this isn't just a conversation between
me and you about the pair pairs have
fascinated me for a long time in my life
i oft bring up pairs to friends at
parties social gatherings and on set
recently on set i said we had a pair of
debate on set and i said raise your hand
if you purchase pairs because people
that's you're blowing my mind you're
blowing my mind now
no no i don't good morning joe
hi geez you're eating that cereal like
it's your job
you know the best part what's that
it's grain free yeah
soy freak yeah low carb yeah and gmo
free
also gluten free keto friendly has zero
sugar
11 grams of protein and only three net
carbs
per serving i bet i know what you're
thinking right
that probably tastes terrible wrong
it tastes great it's magic spoon
cereal is back baby you can eat it
guilt-free
taste it before i taste it
is everything okay at home what is going
on with you things are bad at home
which is why i'm eating cereal all day
for every meal but at least i can eat it
with a clean
conscience coming in four delicious
flavors
fruit blueberry cocoa and frosted i love
all four
but my favorites are fruit and blueberry
i gotta be honest
i love this stuff i gave up cereal years
ago because there was no way to eat it
without having
to die and that's the truth or you had
to eat something that tasted like
like like wood chips or you had to eat
some kind of thing that was supposed to
be good but didn't taste good
this tastes great magic spoon has done
it i don't know how they did it they're
miracle workers they did it i'm being
serious magicspoon.com taste buds that's
where you're going to go
magicspoon.com taste buds once you're
there you're going to enter the promo
code
taste buds you're going to get five
dollars off a variety pack
variety pack containing four flavors
cocoa frosted
fruity blueberry boom and if you don't
like it for whatever reason which you
will love it
i promise you that but if you don't 100
percent happiness guarantee
for any reason you're not satisfied
they're going to refund your money
no questions asked i even like the name
i love the name yeah
magic spoon it's just fun i like it yeah
yeah so
uh we we said try it out let us know how
you like it yeah that's it god bless
go to go to magicspoon.com
taste buds and use the promo code once
you get there taste buds
to save five bucks on that variety pack
thanks a lot gang
sal support for today's episode and the
show taste buds
brought to you by manscaped who is the
best in men's
below the waist grooming we're talking
about the down there
area it offers precision engineered
tools
for your family jewels they obsess over
technology
developments to provide you the best
tools for your grooming experience
two million men worldwide wide are using
manscaped uh
join the movement for all your below the
waist grooming needs i've been using
manscape now for
long before they sponsored us years yeah
uh they make waterproof electric razors
that you can use
in the shower which is a game changer
most clippers if you want to use them
you got to use them out in the regular
room
probably the bathroom but not the
kitchen we don't have to get too into it
yeah but my point is premium it's it's a
lot easier with cleanup and everything
that you can use these things in the
shower whenever you want
right it's not like you're at a barber
shop and you have the kid that they at
the school they're paying five hours an
hour and he's going around with the push
broom yeah
and i'm excited to have their new third
generation trimmer which features a
cutting-edge ceramic blade
to reduce grooming accidents you know
which are bad in this area
thanks to advanced skin safe technology
pioneered by manscape
and the battery's gonna last up to 90
minutes so you can take a longer shave
but let me tell you something
if you need 90 minutes worth of battery
to clean yourself up
you should talk to a friend okay one of
the coolest features by the way is the
led light which illuminates grooming
areas for a closer and more precise yeah
you need the led light because a lot of
times i like to manscape in the dark
so some people shower in the dark you
know it's it's i i
like that it's an option it is get 20
off and free shipping with the code
tastebuds at manscape.com that's
20 off with free shipping that's a great
deal
at manscape.com don't forget use the
code tastebuds who's going to thank you
who's going to thank you uh for my
intimacy my internet partners oh okay
balls are going to thank you this
episode one of our sponsors here is blue
chew
sandwiches blue chew is making waves and
bringing more confidence
into the bedroom by offering chewable
tablets that can help men get stronger
and longer lasting erections which is
the point
blue chew is a unique online service
delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra seals but in a
chewable form at a fraction of
the cost don't like swallowing pills no
problem here yeah
i and i actually have a personal
anecdote i've used blue chew
okay i was in vegas for three days okay
going hard
partying okay had a very lovely lady
friend
okay who i met towards the end of the
run all right she said you know i know
we just met i'd love for you to stay an
extra night and hang out
my body's going it's been blackjack and
booze for three days straight it's time
to go home
yeah baby i popped a blue chew all right
and then you stayed an extra day in
vegas
and then you guys did stuff that adults
do behind closed doors with confidence
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of our
licensed medical providers that they
have
and once you're approved that's it
you'll receive a prescription within
days the best part it's all done
online it's discreet it is affordable
let me tell you the deal that you get
with bluetooth.com with us
you're gonna get blue chew for free when
you use promo code taste buds at
checkout
just pay five bucks for the shipping
that's bluechew.com use promo code
tastebuds and you're gonna receive your
first month
for free just pay the five bucks
shipping we thank you blue chew for
sponsoring the podcast
sally baby do you shop online
my love i do and i love the product that
we're about to talk about all right
why do you love it because you love
promo codes i absolutely love promo
codes and every time i go to check out
and there's a
there's a space to put a promo or a
discount code it psychs me out i will
leave that page and i will do a
hunt on the internet for a valid promo
code and 90
of the time it says it's going to be
valid and it doesn't work so
honey always makes me feel
dirty yeah and weird yeah and then i
might get in trouble
so i'm happy to i'm happy that honey is
here to let us know it's okay
honey this is what honey is so honey is
it's a free browser extension
and it scours the internet for promo
codes and applies the best ones it finds
to your card
you don't have to do the thing i did
that makes us feel bad
anymore it's just odd and it's automatic
so if you're getting it
it supports over 30 000 online stores
and that ranges from things like tech to
gaming products to fashion brands to
food delivery
just wait a few seconds honey searches
for all the coupons and then applies it
when you check out
yeah when you check out a honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons
how easy is that i i i won't shop
another way now
because now i know that if i'm not using
that i might just be losing money
uh and i've saved up to 15 bucks
on things you know what i mean which
which is a lot
you know what it feels good it feels
like you won because you hit you hit a
button and if you didn't hit that button
you know you would have spent that money
i like little victories yeah i like it
very much for the gadget purchases that
i make because
a lot of time when you you'll get a
gadget and you'll say oh that's a good
price for that gadget
and then you get hit with shipping and
you know what i mean it takes it all out
and it takes it all away
with honey in the discount then all of a
sudden you're like oh you're getting it
for
that price you see initially because it
kind of kind of makes up for all the
other 100 and everyone's using it
because
it has over 17 million members and those
people using it have saved over
two billion dollars in savings yeah well
all right so if you haven't done it
already
which i don't understand why you have it
uh go get honey okay because you
straight up are missing out on free
savings it's literally
free and installs in a few seconds and
by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this podcast
go get honey for free at joinhoney.com
taste buds that's join honey dot com
slash taste buds and it's yours
i feel like pears are used in addition
to stuff
like i don't mind a poached pear in like
a nice salad with a garganzola and a
walnut and a mixed green
and maybe i maybe need it what the only
way i won't eat it i don't mind that
i don't mind that but there's no there's
no is there a pear pie
no there's no pear pie is that is there
a pear pie uh
i don't know hair varieties so go back
and also we'll go back to paper ice
because i don't know paired varieties i
know there's a yellow and a green
a botch is a wonderful ride but my
favorite pair
yeah oh my god i guess you could make a
pie into anything but you you [ __ ] on me
about
people don't even know what a peach pie
is i swear to christ
i've never seen heard or ate a pear pot
i swear to you i'm not defending the
pear
pie i've never had it but i can tell you
this right now a a concord pear
a bartlett that i heard of uh a bosch
pair
heard of it uh uh okay a redland
red you can read those i can't the d i
don't know how to say that one
danielle can we can we expand that that
that thing
the pair is wonderful i think you're
really missing out
and the proof that it's better than the
cantaloupe is perfect look at the
variations
you've got eight pairs there oh you've
got ten pairs there oh that's ten
sorry ten pairs there all of which carry
a different flavor
there are tart pears there are very
sweet pears there are pears that are
reminiscent i'll tell you right now i've
seen a bartlett pear in my life and i've
seen a bosque pear in my life and maybe
a concord and i didn't know it was
called a concord
it's brown yellow and green asian pear
okay maybe i've heard of it but it looks
like an apple let's be honest how good
does that crimson pearl
red balloon i never like in pear you
wouldn't want a red angel
never heard of it a secle never heard of
it crimson never heard of it because
the answer is you wouldn't want to bite
that crimson pear if you saw you
wouldn't go that looks
like a delicious piece of fruit the
crimson pear
well i also got news for you i've tasted
the brown the yellow and the green
and i've never tasted the difference in
how they taste at all there's huge
i think i think the pear companies are
trying to name pairs or the different
colors
to make you feel like you're getting
more bang for your buck but i think the
pear has the same bland
i'm trying to be an apple bite i i just
huge differences in pear flavor but
a pair is very you have to get them when
they're ripe and it's very hard they're
hard to judge
let's talk here now we're talking
difficulty in fruit it is difficult it's
it's only
it is difficult but let's talk the
cantaloupe let's talk the flavorless
i've never sent this camera sure hold on
you're wrong about the scentless i've
never been i've never
ever ever been in a produce section i've
never witnessed with my own eyeballs
the fact that you're raising your hand i
say never i never met anyone i
hit my lightning i never met anyone that
was on a game show that's changed since
now i've met both
but i've also never met anyone i've
never seen anyone who purchases pears
i've never seen it i see people picking
up cantaloupes all the time
they always get candles people are
knocking feeling them rolling them
bringing them to parties you you slice
open a cantaloupe you take a deep breath
that is a very
mild fruity fun light yeah mild airy
just it's just a pleasant smell a
cantaloupe is a pleasant smell so the
words you're using
mild airy these are not
it's a springy summery no yes
good smells it's you want a robust smell
you want a flavor
when you bite into a cantaloupe that is
the perfect amount of ripe
it's deep orange it's soft burst with
flavor
no i'm just saying a ripe perfect
cantaloupe is like
it's almost like it's that you know when
you have food and it tastes good and
you're chewing it so everyone gets quiet
like you know people you know good food
is being served all of a sudden when the
talking stops
but like a good camera happens when
you're when you're when you're when
you're chomping on a good cantaloupe
i i have a tendency like i like to like
i almost like sit like a
song comes out of me like if i mean i'll
go like i'll
i'll try to be like let's go
let's go into the next pair i've never
even done i bite one pair and i'm like
it's the same as what i remember
and then i and then i throw it away
you're eating the wrong pairs you're in
the wrong room but let's just take it a
step further let's just take it a step
further okay
we're going to disagree on taste that's
fine let's talk about the disgusting
sight of a cantaloupe middle is gross
i'm not even going to argue that
it looks like it looks like a it looks
like a vagina that took a left turn in
albuquerque
the middle the outside of it
it's almost like a ziggy in the seeds
it's pumpkin it looks like it has
some kind by the way inside of a pumpkin
oh yeah
but it looks like it has some kind of
disease on its skin no it looks like it
needs to be moisturized yes it looks
like a brain
it looks it looks like it needs to be
moisturized okay it's a it's a
hideous hidden moisturized yeah but
talking about the taste
anyway i can't defend the middle of a
cantaloupe i can't do it
i'm looking at it right now and it gives
me the heebie-jeebies pears are
decorative i mean people you see a fake
fruit bowl there's pears
i will say this i will say i will say
you got me there
although too bad we're not talking about
fake fruit and also
people paint still life pair i don't
often see still life paint uh cantaloupe
painted not paintable
candy cause it's an ugly fruit yeah but
i will say yeah because it's just a
circle
but we're not talking about acrylics and
oils right now no i know but
i think a lot of the time ugliness on
the outside is
reflected by the ugliness on the inside
and the cantaloupe is ugly on the inside
it's ugly through and through it is it
sounds like you're
dipping back into nursery rhymes it's
just uh
melon princess and the peas melon sucks
you see melon
okay you see cantaloupe for instance
stanhope's weighing in now
we got we got comics are ken i mean
comics are just weighing in
all right we'll we'll go back to it
we'll go back to it
uh what can you do with a pen i love it
stan hope's on my side yeah yeah
all right i i'll call we should i'll
call him live right hope says
with no melon whatsoever
in his fruit salad he is on my side well
you know what
stan hope is he's also not all there
everybody knows that
everybody knows about him everybody
knows this [ __ ] here's my point i love
you doug
here's my point i love you doug but i
mean the guy lives in a fun house
in the middle of the desert and and he's
everything everything he does is
questionable he's got no sights
and tastes and smells for certain okay
you know that about doug when you go to
his house it's multiple colors
oh it's sensory overload look yeah this
is a guy that knows taste and smell and
he knows that melon stinks
now here's my point cantaloupe bright
orange you look at it you go oh my god
what a burst of orange that's gonna be
wrong uh honeydew you look at it you go
bright green
oh if you're that much of a simpleton
that you're like green
means this taste hold on what a burst of
lime any
citrusy whatever you bite it wrong
watermelon
bright red will that be a cherry or a
strawberry or a raspberry
none of the above wrong melon
sucks okay so melon you can't judge a
book by its cover that's what i'm saying
i actually like the way the melon has
orange and then a
nice bright layer of green and then a
layer of like that
taupe or whatever it is i don't know
okay but it doesn't taste like anything
we're talking about taste buddy a pear
is a bland son of a [ __ ]
that's a ride in the coattails of other
tree-bearing fruits
there's not even pear picking apples
apples i
told you how shitty it is cantaloupe
picking
no but but cantaloupes don't grow in
trees i don't think
nobody knows where they come from well
they but listen to me they fall
it's like disgusting we talked about
this apple pharma's like it's a dollar
for the whole family please take as many
as you can carry on right right
okay pairs grow on trees as well there
isn't any pair picking do you know why
because for one dollar
for one dollar for one dollar nobody
wants a pair even as for as many as they
could pick you know why else cantaloupe
sucks
it only can be cantaloupe it's got
zero versatility cantaloupes cantaloupe
goes into no
the only way i like cantaloupe ready for
this the only way i ever like cantaloupe
is with prosciutto wrapped around it
because
it's amazing masks the hardness no it
doesn't it
they complement each other it doesn't
mask it it needs then why wouldn't you
just eat prosciutto alone that's how
shitty cantaloupe is it needs ham it's
prosciutto to elevate it
no it doesn't literal ham it does not
elevate it
no no no no no no no no the the
cantaloupe is elevating the project and
vice versa
it doesn't need it it complements each
other
what do you i mean dude honestly i'll
give you a pear
with like a goat cheese or a garganzolo
with a walnut i need a lot of things at
play i need a raspberry vinaigrette in
there
i need a mixed green or baby leaf
spinach that's how i could have a pear
poach it oh
i don't want it here's how i do if you
walked into my house right now and i was
like could i get you a pear
honestly i swear to god has anyone ever
said that to you
no but if i put out a fruit tray it's
going to have a variety of fruit and
cantaloupe's going to be in it
could you imagine if you came over and i
had company and i put out a plate of
sliced pear
nobody does it do you know why it's
unacceptable it's
unacceptable apple i mean it's there's
fruits you don't put out
okay but even pierce would you put out
banana chunks nobody does that either
bananas suck point taken but what i'm
saying is
even in a bowl i wouldn't be like get
yourself a pear at will get yourself a
beer
i wouldn't even put a pear in a bowl at
my house and say
by the way whoever wants a pair there's
a bowl of them do you know if i put i
will do
i will do i will i will challenge you
this
the next time like we have like we have
a super bowl party again
what i'll do is i'll put out a bowl of
pears and i'll put out
a tray of sliced cantaloupe and we will
see
what gets eaten more but we'll take it
right to the we'll take it we'll make it
into it guess what guess what we're back
to
we're back to the classic because here's
the thing that doesn't that doesn't mean
anything
because you could also put out a tray of
beautiful
uh cured italian meat sandwiches next to
a tray
of [ __ ] turkey with pesto sauce on
wheat bread and guess what
people are gonna eat the goddamn turkey
with pesto sauce and wheat bread because
they think it's better for them
why don't more people have pears why why
why have i never
seen a person purchase a pear why have i
never been offered a pear in a home
why have i never gone into a home and
seen pears in a bowl it's not a fruit
salad dish
you've never been offered people in the
house i'm talking yes i have
you yes people are offering you apples
when you walk into their houses i mean
there's a bowl of apples yeah a bowl of
fruit has apples oranges bananas
grapes even pear i mean a pear is in the
traditional
that bowl but never been offered fruits
of any kind all right you walk into a
house there's a big bowl it's like a
still life
your typical still life bowl it's got
grapes
oranges apples bananas and pears you're
telling me you reach for the pear you go
like this and you cry you bite into the
paper what i'm in the mood for
so you can't even you don't even know if
i'm gonna move for a pair i'm gonna eat
a goddamn pear
i like pears you weigh them you put them
in a little bag and you weigh them and
you pay for them i put them in a bag i
don't give a [ __ ] what they cost
that's how much i like them i don't even
weigh them i just say whatever that
costs i'll pay it
that's what i do that's how i work hair
feels like
like it was trying to be a fruit real
hard and then
and then it just gave up that's what the
cantaloupe is
you have not seen one picture of
every picture they showed of cantaloupe
it was look we use it as a bowl to put
disgusting cottage cheese in
look it's part of a fruit salad look i
put cereal
nothing but just a pear sitting there
that's my point because people eat just
pears cantaloupe is like ah you can do
all this fun stuff
people don't eat pears if you'd said if
you ranked now this is something i
researched the other day i swear to god
in western civilization there is over 2
000 fruits
and i was at about i was at my
i was at i was at my friend's backyard
and i said how many fruits do you think
we could name
and we all chipped in and we ended up
naming how many fruits you think we can
name
20. i originally thought about 32 we end
up naming 42 fruits
okay okay but um well i don't know
that's a sidebar it'd be a fun little
thing for us to do
but if you said to people what are your
top 10 fruits
i think that pear does not crack the
majority of people's
top 10 fruits so not only am i saying a
pear is not worthy of a top spot or
or someone's delicious go-to a pear is
so
far down the ladder on people's fruits
people will eat a pear if they have to
nobody
pear is the forgotten fruit pear is
parrot like the pear is a staten island
of fruits let me explain to you
let me explain to you what the
difference is and why everybody likes
cantaloupe
cantaloupe is the is the friend you can
always rely
on somebody that's always there
he's he's a nice follow me he's a nice
guy
but he doesn't really bring much to the
table yeah sure he doesn't like the room
up
sure he's not funny sure he's not
charismatic but he's a good kid
so we keep him around pear is rogue
the pair goes rogue people don't pay
they go it's a little too weird for me
it's a little too dangerous i don't know
about that guy over there
that's who the pear is you dig is an air
of mystery to the pair people don't know
a lot about the pair the pair might be a
bad boy
it does its own thing and it sticks to
itself is my point it sticks to itself
that's why you're not seeing it pear
doesn't try to be anything it's not yeah
it's not sliced in half or cottage
cheese in it people are using this
cantaloupe for everything but you've
been eating cantaloupe not just my point
that's not true
all right go to the polls going to the
polls holy cow
that was the i mean i didn't think we
were going to go that far this was
born out of last episodes and that last
episode riff
holy [ __ ] now i will say we got
ourselves a barn burner
meaning a barn burner and also it gets
closer to this
it's close oh okay it's the closest
we've ever had
in the four episode run so far it's it
it is it might be rematch territory
okay okay and i just saw it and i
interpret it
wrong because remember we inversed it
so the higher percentage is the worst
fruit so the higher percentage in this
case is the loser
yeah you get that yes because it took me
a minute to adjust to that
in this case you got 53 percent
to 47 percent who's up to 7
400 votes humble pie the worst fruit
by 53 percent to even the score out i am
eating the humble pie
cantaloupe cantaloupe at 53 was that
ah this is a this one is gonna be a hard
pill to swallow
this is a hard pill to swallow at three
percent at the 7 400 votes
ah oh that feels good
i mean we're talking a couple of hundred
votes difference here man
that feels good plus i got stanhope on
my side look at this guy
oh this is the lead
this is the worst fruit is oh man
oh man oh boy oh boy i disagree
let me put my i disagree let's read some
of these
uh i hate the texture of pears flavor is
good texture is ew
cantaloupe is my second favorite fruit
behind the pineapple
i'm mad at this poll i don't trust
anyone that voted for cantaloupe
cantaloupe just ruins the watermelon in
a fruit cup or fruit salad
uh that's difficult pair not even close
i love cantaloupe take pair off this
immediately off this wow
cantaloupe should win by a landslide
pairs are so gross this is blasphemy
cantaloupe is nearly the best of all
fruits
cantaloupe vile thing that gets my vote
for best
cantaloupe is my second favorite fruit
behind pineapple i'm mad at this pole
uh pears are just soggy fancy apples
thank you that's a good one cantaloupe
is soggy fancy apples
pears are just soggy don't put
cantaloupe
pears are just soggy fancy apples that's
a great one that's good that's our
so far oh my god
what i i'm eating cantaloupe right now
and i love pears you can have a nice
juicy crunchy pear but a cantaloupe is
never good pears are like a top three
fruit so frankly i'm confused and
offended
both are disgusting but i voted pear
worse i'm usually only eating one
cantaloupe in a fruit cup when i'm
reminded it's terrible
i decided to give pears a go again
given they share the first four letters
with my shirt
okay sal don't start pears are
delightful
both of these fruits are amazing and
underrated worst fruit honeydew
cantaloupes and pears are delish
oh my buddy brian lynch you know what
salad cantaloupe is great go to hell
i thought you weren't i thought you also
he agrees with me but he's telling me to
go to hell
why is he assuming what i think is the
worst scripture because none of them
know that i'm part of these polls
and they're just assuming that but still
i'm just asking oh so he's not
right we might have a winner right here
i'm thinking so they think i think
both of them yeah oh we might have a
winner right here go up what's this gif
pears are nasty
you're a little nasty
that's a really good one how dare 47
percent of people say pear is the worst
fruit have you all eaten a cantaloupe
before
absolute garbage
you can have a nice juicy crunchy pear
but a cantaloupe is never good
cantaloupe and it's not even close
both are disgusting a pear is a worst
apple at least a cantaloupe is original
smh
we always get a lot a little smh in
there all right fair enough
a pear just tastes like a mushy apple i
learned to love cantaloupe as an adult
see oh my god cantaloupe is like eat
soap
[Laughter]
prosciutto ham and cantaloupe is bomb as
af
let's see do you have it cantaloupe
should win by a landslide
why is it grapefruited option i will
tell you grapefruit's my most hated
fruit
well we weren't discussing that what we
weren't discussing that i know but
how do you feel about grapefruit uh
grapefruit i like
if there's some sugar sprinkle on it so
you don't want it so you don't like
grapefruit
like great i straight but here's the
thing i love grapefruit juice in a drink
pear worse hands down it's like
sandpaper
don't disagree what kind of monsters are
out voting against pairs how are these
results even so close
cantaloupes grow from alien demon seamen
that's the winner shout outs to just
sparkles
uh her handle is at c-a-l-l-a-d-h-i-e-l
again that's at c-a-l-l-a-d-h-i-e-l
where is that i gotta give her a like
yeah you are our winner she's down
towards the bottom of the comments
uh and that's our show folks we are now
2-2 in the food debates uh
i still love you buddy i love you too
[Laughter]
also pat walsh and myself have a show
called we'll see you and how
we review movies of all genres uh
back catalog available wherever you get
your shows uh and on starburns media and
the
new episodes are on patreon.com wsyih
podcast you got brian lynch charmin and
stan hope we have
um willie garson my buddy who is in
every movie you've ever seen since the
day we were
we were born and ethan soupley we got
people people are
look people are responding to these
polls they don't even know that this is
part of a podcast yet i'm going to tweet
that i'm going to say i want you all to
know
this is part of a new podcast that we're
doing called taste buds so
this is not just me it's me and i'm
going to send out a tweet
so then people will hopefully know but
this is i mean people
can't help but chime in i'm loving this
this is exactly how we plan um i got a
um i love it
uh a podcast with krista stefano called
hey babe um
i wonder if me and cue will ever get uh
for all the people that are gonna say
what happened to what say you what
happened to what say you uh me and quinn
love doing it we stopped for a little
bit maybe we'll start again one day
and we'll come back so everyone who says
that just know that it's not gone
forever and me and
me and q mate may come back and we may
do it um
uh yeah and just watch uh dinner party
and misery index and jokers
and uh when i ever have a tour dates
again i'll let you know
um until until then uh it's all about
hey babe
and taste buds uh thank you guys so much
tastebuds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs